over nearly 10 years of making weekly
videos for this channel I've made some
mistakes when they're significant I will
pin a comment to the video I'll add a
card and I'll make a note on the
corrections page on my website but not
many people will see those compared to
the original video so with only a few
weeks left until I stop posting regular
Monday videos I figure it's time to
officially look back at all the things I
got wrong in the last 10 years and all
these mistakes are sponsored by nordvpn
which I have no regrets about using and
whose black Friday sale is now on so
what counts as a significant enough
mistake for this video well it has to
affect the truth of what I said an
editing glitch or a typo in a caption or
a mispronunciation they don't count
they're still going to Haun me for the
rest of my days but they happen and it
has to be a regular Monday video that's
live on this channel if it's a mistake
in another show it doesn't count I am
sure that some of the facts on lateral
the podcast I run will turn out to be
wrong in future despite the question
writer's best efforts but here we're
dealing with this series and this
channel you should go and listen to
lateral after I hated writing this new
script by the way I despise anything
I've made in the past this was not
pleasant to look back on particularly my
early stuff but that's where we start
2014 when my research usually involved
typing a couple of things into Google to
check that I'd remembered them properly
the UK has four Trident class nuclear
submarines yes I looked younger 10 years
ago never mind it'll happen to you as
well and the old Alternatives worse
anyway Trident is the nuclear missile
the submarines are Vanguard class this
is where I should have learned to check
every little fact in the video not just
the big one but I still screw that up
sometimes I hate that video I nearly
pulled it entirely tardia which is
irregular heartbeat nope tardia is an
accelerated heartbeat again I thought I
knew a word and so I didn't check it
also hold the phone further from your
face what these have is a Bim metallic
strip modern toasters don't use bi
metallic strips they use either variable
resistors charged by capacitors or
specialized silicon Alec over at
technology connections has a great video
about them ironically my video was meant
to correct the internet and I got a big
detail in it wrong now in 2015 I went to
spard and I talked about the 24-hour
Sundial there are several places I went
to early in things you might not know
and I wish I I'd save them for later and
that's definitely one of those places
anyway I said it is the summer equinox
today as I record this I said summer
equinox it's the summer solstice The
Equinox is in Spring and Autumn when the
days and nights are almost equal length
it's in the name Equinox equal night yes
I know it's more technical than that I
don't care later that year I was talking
about Concord again not a good video
but in 2003 the airlines decided that it
just wasn't work running anymore that's
a really subtle mistake and it's in the
timing the words are correct but I
basically moved a comma in my head and
that in the subtitles the crash was in
2000 the airlines decommissioned Concord
in 2003 I should have said after one of
the planes crashed in 2003 the airlines
decided actually I should have just
Rewritten the whole section next video
about tracking nuclear explosions from
Cold War bunkers ground bursts that
produce local Fallout Air Bursts that
spread it much wider wrong way round
ground bursts from nuclear explosions
spread more Fallout than Air Bursts and
they spread it wider which makes sense
given they're blowing up the ground and
not the air next up the St Francis Dam
near Angeles more than 50 m High holding
back 100,000 tons of water the St
Francis Dam actually held back not
100,000 but 47 million tons of water I
Mook the volume of the physical dam for
the volume of the reservoir it held back
in my defense volume calculations are
really unintuitive 2016 then the year
with the most errors and we start with a
great one in the original version of the
video game civilization gandi was a dick
just to be clear I am talking about the
virtual representation of Gandhi in a
fictional video game that story was
meant to be true at the time you could
find loads of Articles testifying that a
bug in the game civilization meant that
the virtual gandi score for aggression
could go negative and then Loop Round to
being massive but years after I put that
video out turns out it was some giant
Collective false memory that bug does
not exist I've never actually played the
game now I also had a whole video called
why you should write down your goals
might be the worst video I've ever done
and I say had because I decided to move
it to being un listed after watching it
back for this it's just a confusing mess
tacked onto a weird story about
television and based on one or two
research papers and this was before the
replication crisis too when Psychology
was still flush with astonishing results
about how people could be subconsciously
influenced and affected by things a lot
of those Studies have not survived
attempts to recreate them Thomas Frank
made a great video arguing the
Counterpoint I'm not sure I'd agree with
that either though and I suspect the
answer to whether you should write down
your goals is I don't know depends on
you you now there was the time that me
and my friends Matt and Paul drove along
a road that goes through Russia for
about 1 km and as long as you don't stop
you don't technically enter Russia you
don't need a visa 2016 wouldn't do that
video now but as we're approaching Matt
says that pole yes is where they're
spying from oh oh you're right yeah no
it was just a cell tower or at least
that's what they want us to think there
is no evidence for it being any more
than that that is my responsibility to
check before putting it in the video
Matt had just noticed a thing and said
it and because it felt more like a vlog
I kept it in my fault not his next one I
was talking about turbines in thermal
power plants hundreds of tons of steel
rotating thousands of times a second no
no they they spin thousands of times per
minute not per second obviously if your
giant electricity turbine is spinning
several thousand times a second
something is very wrong and probably on
fire I just said the wrong word probably
because I was kind of stressed from
being on top of a wind turbine next up
the first time that I have to correct a
mistake from an interviewee I'm not
going to play the actual clip back it
doesn't feel fair to point out someone
who was kind enough to give an interview
many years ago but I was talking to one
of the administrators of West Virginia
University about their personal rapid
transit system the PRT and he said the
PRT never shuts down yes it does at
night on Sundays outside term times
regularly when there were mechanical
failures like that shouldn't have made
the edit I guess it was said
aspirationally or metaphorically but
another word for that would be wrong and
to be clear that's on me it's my job to
make sure that the people I interview
don't end up saying something silly in
the final video right 2017 things start
getting a little better here I start
finding my style with 3 years into
making these videos and I'm actually
starting to fact check things properly
only one error that whole year but it's
a doozy from the zero gravity drop tower
in Breman Germany in the first second
after release the drop capsule goes 10 m
next second 20 next next second 30 next
second 40 and then we've used up pretty
much all the height there is that is
wrong yes the speed increases by 10 m/s
per second I know it's actually 9.8
something but like 10 m/s is close
enough for this but that doesn't mean it
travels 10 m in the first second cuz
it's starting at zero and speeding up it
had travel 5 m in the first second then
15 then 25 and so on two separate
physicists fact check that script zero
gravity is really confusing 2018 then
one error in the 20th century more than
200,000 tons of gold were extracted from
the rock underneath here giant mine in
Canada produced 200,000 kilos of gold
not tons they also produce 200,000 tons
of aric trioxide dust which is the
problem they now have you can see how I
got confused with those numbers 200,000
tons of gold would be roughly the same
amount that the entire world has mined
throughout history so you know just
slightly out there 2019 two weird
mistakes in the same computer science
script if I want to run it on a
completely different type of computer a
Mac instead of a PC I can compile it for
that CPU instead nope I meant phone
instead of PC although given the recent
switch to Apple silicon that's probably
now true and we're counting upwards by
one on every sixth clock cycle that's
every ninth cycle it's obvious from the
graphics and I just said the wrong words
and didn't notice during the edit 2020 I
know that I said typos and onscreen
Graphics don't count but when you get
the speed of light wrong you copied and
pasted a one into the wrong place yeah
it counts the other error is more
interesting though I was talking about
the rules on where British programs can
break for adverts and the host says time
for a break like it's really clear
that's not allowed there's no other way
to read that sentence that was true back
20 plus years ago when the original
version of millionaire came out but in
2008 the rules were changed it's now
ambiguous whether that's allowed the old
broadcasting code was still on the
regulator site it was wasn't flagged as
being replaced and I just didn't spot
that I was using the old version in my
script 2021 skipping over the 18th
century firefighters video that I did a
long correction for last year we have
two blunders even the big lithium ion
setup in Australia that's only caught on
fire once so far just like that line
years earlier about Trident class
submarines I just thought I knew what I
was talking about and I didn't double
check it the graphics are wrong
hornsdale power Reserve didn't catch
fire it was the newer Victorian big
battery near gong complete blunder on my
part sorry to hornsdale team your
battery did not catch on fire and then a
translation mistake shvan Firearms was
mistakenly transcribed as schutz vaen
defensive weapons my transcriber and
translator was German but not Swiss
German and that's a pretty easy mistake
to make honestly I'm not sure I got it
the right way around in this video 2022
no errors that are still online but in
this video about a chain mail box
surrounding a house I did originally
suggest that the chain mail was all hand
led the Sheets Were hand linked but
those sheets were made by Machine the
correction still up but for once it was
a very brief line that could be easily
and cleanly cropped out using YouTube's
editor so I just did that and then this
year at least this year so far Yan Anton
bacher's birth year is 1898 not 1989 you
can see exactly how that happened and
the recent video from the British
Library said that if you want to get a
library card here there will be a short
interview about your research and why
you can't just pull the books or
material you want from your local
University Library apparently the formal
interview requirement for a reader pass
which I had to go through a few years
ago has now been dropped there will no
doubt be more mistakes there probably
one in this video because that would be
ironic and it's probably going to happen
when that happens please remember
hanlin's Razer which says in short
up before conspiracy you should never
attribute to malice what can be
adequately explained by stupidity as for
what has been useful for my research
well nordvpn's Black Friday deal is on
really do use them a lot while I'm
traveling because being able to tap
nordvpn's Magic button and pretend that
my computer and phone are in any one of
around 60 countries is really useful
there are websites that block visitors
from certain countries which is
unhelpful there may be other content you
want to access through GE restrictions
too just check the terms of service
first and I save money on car rental
because sometimes I can get a cheaper
quote if my computer appears to be back
in the UK nordvpn works on six devices
simultaneously across Mac Windows Linux
and Android and iOS and there a 30-day
money back guarantee so if you're not
sure it's for you try it anyway I'm
happy to keep endorsing them because I
really do use them and don't worry if
you're watching this later whenever you
go to nordvpn.com tomscot by clicking
the link in the description or scanning
the QR code you'll still get the best
deal they're currently offering but if
you're on the fence Now's the Time to
try